welcome to DCT next of note today
morning on the Twitter feed notice
there's someone saying Oh Nova here's
the keynotes and we have Disney we have
Home Depot we have HSBC Google's going
all enterprise words of the nerd stuff
well here's the nerd stuff so welcome to
the nerd stuff right what we're going to
talk about today is how to do data
science on GCP all right who does data
science on GCP data engineers right so
we're going to talk about how a data
engineer can do data science on GCP and
how GCP makes that easy makes it auto
scale make it auto awesome the popular
imagination if I told you what machine
learning is machine learning has been in
the air today right then we say what is
machine learning people say well you
have lots of data you do some really
complex math somehow and outcomes magic
right that's basically what people's
imagination of ML is in reality though
what does ml ml is a lot of work you're
going to spend a lot of time and effort
collecting the data you're going to use
all your ingenuity all your knowledge
all your experience to organize this
data and then you're going to basically
bring your insights your domain
expertise in order to create a model
that somehow represents what you know
about the domain that you're working in
and how it relates to the data and then
you're ready to go once you have this
model in place you can now train this
model and that training is all very
automatic and then you end up in magic
right you do end up in magic but in
order to get there is a lot of work and
what GCP can help you with is to make
this work much more tractable much
easier to do so what we're talking about
here is that GCP is a place where data
science meets data engineering and I
would like to introduce
used to you my two colleagues Razer
who's going to play the part of a data
engineer myself I'm lack so we're going
to play this role of myself as a CTO the
head of BI for a company called alpha
Plex we make widgets and Alex here
another of my colleagues is going to
play the part of a data engineer so
what's the scenario the scenario here is
that we run a factory and in our factory
we make widgets and of course a factory
has a bunch of different machines and
these machines heat up the factory floor
right we have we have a factory these
machines heat up the factory floor we
have people working in these factories
so we have to ensure that this factory
is efficiently cooled we need to make
sure that we're not spending too much
and cooling the factory but if the
factory floor gets too hot then we're
going to result in wear and tear so we
need to figure out the optimal way to
cool the factory floor fortunately we've
been collecting data right when
collecting data and we'll be able to use
that data to solve this problem of how
to efficiently cool the factory floor
what we need to do is that we have a
factory we have an air conditioner and
we need to figure out when to switch on
the AC if this sounds familiar to you
this is kind of the same issue that we
do in Google data centers when we need
to basically figure out how to
efficiently cool a data center this is a
common problem right so we need to
figure out when to switch the a/c on we
have a bunch of different machines right
in these machines essentially heat up
and cool up cool down right the the
factory so we basically figured out how
to keep these machines and how to keep
the people at safe temperatures and what
data we have is the inside temperature
of the factory the outside temperature
and the reason we have that is because
we went to achieve scientist Isaac
and Isaac told us that he actually has
this formula right so Isaac has this
formula that said now if you know the
inside temperature and you have the
outside temperature you do all of this
math I'll tell you that you have a bowl
of soup how long is it going to take
that bowl of soup to cool down so Isaac
says he has the exact formula but we say
hey Newton hold your horses right we
don't want to basically use that formula
because real life is a bit more
complicated than just a bowl of soup why
is it more complicated because right we
can monitor the inside temperature we
can monitor the outside temperature but
there are other complicating factors
complicating factors like right which
machines are running how many machines
are running right what are the machines
doing and how much are they heating
things up well how many people are in
the factory and all of these kinds of
things make applying that heuristic that
rules that we had really hard to do and
if you think about machine learning in
the real world it's usually a
replacement for you used to have bunch
of data user formulas used to have rules
you should have heuristics and now you
change those out and replace them by
something that learns from the data so
we have collected data over time about
the factories inside temperature the
outside temperature what was running in
the factory right at different points in
time we have that data and so we will
basically show you that that journey
right but first let's start where we are
and let's say that we know things about
a factory floor we know the inside
temperature we know the outside
temperature let's figure out how to
basically balance the cost of cooling
versus the cost of the repairs that are
going to result if we let the
temperature get too high right that's
basically the balance that we have to
strike so razor let's build something
cool okay so I am the data engineer and
we're a small company and so in terms of
the number of data engineers we have
just me
so we have some constraints in terms of
how much stuff I am able to do and one
of the lines that lacks edge very
casually is we've been collecting data
now as a data engineer that line is
potentially quite a lot of work for me
so let's have a look about the kind of
thing that we needed to put together to
actually collect that data so we have
this Factory and again we have one data
engineer I want to make sure that
anything that I'm writing is first of
all production grade - it will scale out
so while we might be doing an experiment
right now with one factory I want to
make sure that if we have factories
across the globe if we have many
thousands of IOT devices in that factory
recording things like temperature number
of people maybe tomorrow it's thought
measuring things about the machines
themselves and sending that information
on no matter how much data I have I want
to be able to always absorb this data
coming from all of these IOT devices and
it's important I do this in stream mode
one it's important for the data
collection and the processing but - as
we come to see when we want to do some
more inference on that data points the
the next piece of collecting after
collecting the data there's a couple of
other things I'm going to need to do
first of all I'm going to need to do
some processing and again one engineer I
want to make sure whatever I write is
very small amount of code and the system
that I'm using are fully managed so I
don't have to wake up at 3 o'clock in
the morning to restart servers or to do
things like rebalance things because our
loads have gone up in that processing
I'm going to do two very simple things
first I'm going to element-wise take
that data to a repository for the
propeller heads to be able to do their
smart data science the other branch of
this is my very basic check to when to
turn the AC system on and that is a
simple test that I'm going to run a
sliding window across the streaming data
that's coming in that sliding window is
going to be five minutes long for the
purpose of this demo I'm just going to
do it every the period of that sliding
windows going to be 15 seconds so every
15 seconds that five minute window is
going to slide down I'm going to do a
calculation of a mean and I'm going to
do a really simple check which is if the
value is over thirty degrees centigrade
then
turn the AC on I'm from UK so it would
be centigrade right okay so let's think
about the components that I'm going to
use first of all I want to use Google
cloud pub/sub API it's a fully managed
publishing API it meets the requirements
for its global so I can have many
factories all sending messages to the
API I have a single topic so I don't
need to worry about today I've got 100
messages a second tomorrow I have
hundreds of thousands of messages a
seconds I don't need to recharge I don't
need to think about partitioning I just
keep sending information into that topic
the next piece of the puzzle is the
processing side so I'm going to take
this data that's coming from pub/sub and
I want to process it one of the other
advantages of pub/sub is that it is H a
and it will hold on to all information
sent to it for up to seven days until
its subscriber pulls the message and
both and also acknowledges that that
message has been removed so the
component that I'm going to connect to
this is data flow and data flow allows
us to do both batch and stream
processing in a pipeline I'm in this
case we're just going to use the
streaming capabilities data flow will
take care of spinning up machines also
healing all that other stuff that again
I don't want to be concerned with I just
want to write simple declarative code on
what my pipeline should do and then let
the system get on with it in that
pipeline I'm going to have two branches
the first branch is to go to bigquery
which is where we're going to store our
information there are multiple choices
of where you could land IOT data
especially at this time series BigTable
could be another option however just
want to run queries against this system
so bigquery is a very good place to land
this data the other branch is the simple
test I want to do take this the mean of
the sliding window if it's over 30
degrees then tell the AC to either come
on or off and in this case we're
actually going to use pub/sub again
although we haven't gotten its diagram
the reason we're using pumps up now is
not as an ingestion mechanism but as the
glue amongst my data pipeline so when I
have a message I put it back into
pub/sub it can communicate with
downstream systems in the factories to
be able to turn this AC on and just to
see how this would look on our pipeline
as it's running
you connect to the laptop please thank
you so this is the monitoring UI from
data flow and it's actually showing the
pipeline in motion we've got the IOT
devices being pushing data into a topic
that I am reading from I am then parsing
the IOT data so it's coming in JSON
format I'm extracting the bits that I
need and then it branches out the first
branch is it element-wise is sending
data to bigquery and by element-wise I
mean there's no micro batching or
batching so as data is flowing in it's
immediately available to any queries the
guys want to run on the other side I am
doing our sliding windows so I create a
5-minute sliding window I will then
extract the temperature from the data
they exist within that 5-minute window
pass it to a mean function from there
we will check if the value is over 30
degrees centigrade if it is I'm going to
send it to two locations the first
location again is that pops up so that
it actually can talk to the factory's
downstream the other location is
actually to firebase and the reason I'm
sending it to firebase I'm going to show
you here so this is that basic test it's
not information being sent on to the
firebase engine and this is essentially
to help us visualize a tool so as the
data gets updated that fact that it's
gone yellow means there was the latest
update from data flow pushing to it now
I can actually visualize this in things
like graphs that connect to the firebase
engine and as you'll notice you actually
know when my laptop was down because
we've got these flat lines going up
because it didn't have any data at that
point and it's just jumped across so
this system will scale could we go back
to the slide please
okay so the amount of code I had to
write this is the code for the data flow
section for pub/sub I just created a
topic there's nothing other than a
DevOps action there in terms of the code
these are snippets but just to give you
a flavor in dataflow data that comes in
gets turned into a parallel collection
of immutable objects and what we do with
that collection is we run a series of
transforms against the data the
first transform I do is saying I want a
sliding window so here those three lines
at the top with a window into sliding
window duration five minutes with a
period of 15 seconds of course if we
were doing this for real we wouldn't use
15 seconds we don't want the AC to come
on and off that quickly you'd put it at
five minutes but then you wouldn't see
the nice flashing indication on the
firebase next I want to actually do the
calculation of the mean mean some
accounts all of these are standard
things that people want to do with data
in pipelines so there's a primitive
built into data flow that single line of
code allows me to get the mean from
every single window next we do our very
trivial test the check threshold and
that check threshold is nothing other
than returning a boolean if the value of
the mean is over 30 degrees centigrade
so that's our very basic pipeline now
we're going to hand it over to our very
smart data scientists we're going to do
some magic with that data okay
so I didn't get the mobile microphone so
I have to stand here which is great
because otherwise I run off so from a
data science point of view what we just
I mean what we just saw was we have a
rule in place for deciding when to turn
the AC on and off and that rule was you
know it's a temperature bigger than 30
or less than 30 right so so it's like
Google with many of our products we've
been doing this rule-based decisions in
our products a lot and only last couple
of years we turn to machine learning to
actually improve the way our products
work to make predictions and increase
the quality so one example is right if
you do a search on Giants it depends on
probably where you are depends you know
if you're in San Francisco here you
might be interested in the San Francisco
Giants probably if you're in New York it
might be different types of Giants
football team versus baseball team so we
used to write these rules where you say
okay here's the query you know then
based on the location
in San Francisco or New York we we give
the user different search results that
are you know focused on on what the user
is probably desiring in my case I'm from
Germany so you know if I search for
Giants it might be the Dortmund Giants
which I didn't even know existed but I
was searching for teaming of course
there's a German giant team so rankbrain
is a good example of how we switch from
using rules to going to machine learning
because instead of just looking at the
search terms themselves and how how
often they appear in a text in our post
they are to each other we actually use
natural language processing to determine
the relevance of a document and this is
the third-highest
you know ranking criteria on how we
determine whether search results is
further up or further down and this is
the biggest improvement we've seen in in
our search quality and last couple of
years so we turn to our problem right we
want to cool the factory we have this
temperature coming in of 27 degrees and
then we're trying to decide you know
what how do we react if the altitude
outside temperature is higher or lower
then we have different number of
machines running and then you have new
factors right so now people give up heat
as well so you might want to consider
that but maybe the there's different
factories with different factory sizes
with different number of air
conditioning units that you can set to
different levels there's all very
different criteria so you can see
turning on or off the AC based on these
rules can become very very hard to do or
impossible to do so machine learning has
been around for you know seems like
hundreds of years so Isaac is thinking
now could we use machine learning for
this maybe instead so just a little 101
on machine learning and
in this case deep learning which I'll
show you in a couple of minutes and how
it works basically is supervised
learning we steep learning here is one
method of machine learning that works
really well for the stuff we do in
Google and it works by taking a lot of
you know a lot of label data that you
know that the Hat dog whatever it is you
train you train a model in the first
step then you evaluate how well is this
doing so you have training data sets you
have test data set you find out the
quality and you do this in an iterative
approach until you have a quality that
that you desire and then what you can do
is right you can take that model put it
on the phone
build a cool app to take a picture of a
cat in this site this is a cat or not
right so this would be applying them to
the model the model so we're going to
also use this for our problem here so we
can we are because this is all life
we're training a model based on all this
data that is already being captured in
victory right so we have number of
machines inside temperature may be
number of people or other factors that
you can use and then you can apply this
model to actually make a decision to
turn on or off the AC whenever you do
machine learning it or it's you're
trying to optimize for something right
so in in this guy in this case we're
trying to minimize the cost and cost in
our case is the cost the the wear and
tear of the machines right because we're
saying we don't want the temperature too
high because it is bad for the machines
they need to run at a certain room
temperature and we want to minimize the
cost of maintenance of buying new
machines right so this is just checking
that the temperatures not too high and
on the other side we don't want the AC
running 24/7 because
that's going to cost energy and we don't
want we don't want to do that we want to
be efficient in how we use that energy
to power the AC right so we're defining
a cost factor which is a combination of
those two factors and we're trying to
balance this out turns out Google has
its own factory floors right our data
centers and we're actually applying
machine learning here too to optimize
how we walk run certain workloads you
can imagine a lot of the workloads that
we do are actually around machine
learning right so we're updating models
and improving our recommendations on cat
videos and stuff like this and it
doesn't matter if this is running in
Oregon or in Finland or anywhere else so
machine learning is a good criteria to
actually make that decision for us and
we've been able to reduce energy costs
to up to 40 percent when we apply
machine learning and there's actually a
cool white paper out there's a there's a
URL on there where it talks about how we
do this and these are some of the
features used to actually create a model
that is optimizing our our own data
centers so if you remember our
architecture that we had just a couple
of minutes ago we're taking that all
that data we're pushing it into bigquery
now we want to take the data and train a
model so you might have heard of tensor
flow it's great because I can just
download it it's open source and I can
do this here on my laptop which I'm
actually going to do the cool thing is I
can then when I'm happy with what I'm
having with the data size the small data
size that I'm testing with I can
actually flip the switch and say now I
want to Train on on the billion data set
with all the factories all right so
doing that switch is fairly easy right
training with a smaller data set locally
but then going full production
and not being needing to be scared if
it's you know on the if the dataset gets
too big or the features to get to the
crime so to demonstrate this I'm going
to be using something called cloud data
lab which is a Jupiter notebook
hosted by by Google cloud and I will be
going into that myth now if that's
possible can we switch to a demo again
thank you so this is a choppier lab this
is a notebook so I can pretty cool
because I can share this with colleagues
and we can we can try to find a cool way
to work with this data right so this is
cool for experimentation I can write and
run Python code in here
I can run tensorflow it's one of the
easiest way to run tensorflow but I can
also pull in a lot of the Python
libraries that are out there like
handlers that we're going to use here as
well so I'm not going to run everything
here obviously you need to do some setup
right we need to define the project and
the cloud storage bucket and these type
of things need to import some libraries
define a schema that is representing
schema that we have in victory here we
are actually going to pull the data
using the query so you can actually see
the career in here and we're in that
where we are also defining the cost so
we're taking a factor of which is called
unsafe which is the time that machines
ran in an unsafe temperature which is
above 30 degrees and we also have a
factor of how much energy was used right
the power that we used on the AC so we
have a cost we have
the temperature when the fan was turned
on the number of machines and the
outside temperature so we're pulling
that into a panda's data frame we're
doing if you remember right we we have
all that data to Train on now we're
going to split the data into a training
and a training data set and that data
set to evaluate or training so this is
happening so where we're using a ninety
you know 90/10 split of training data
and testing data and this is the output
of some of the rows right in here so you
see the cost the fan on the number of
machines outside temperature that's very
cool so I'm going to go little further
down to the part where we're actually
going to train based on all that data
right so we're pulling all the data from
bigquery and we're going to train a
model using tensorflow
it has two hidden layers which says it
right here it says the number of
iterations so we're going to go through
and we have two in layers one with 64
neurons and one with four neurons so I'm
actually going to run that and hopefully
something will happen so this should
just take not more than seven seconds so
it says local training done so that
means it's taking it crazes model and
it's turn is putting it in a in a
directory that we specified right so now
we have model in the directory and now
we can do some prediction on that data
right so we can give it some
temperatures from inside outside number
of machines running and it's going to
give us back a cost factor right so
[Music]
here is here comes the important parts
where we actually now determine evaluate
how how well did our model actually do
right so remember we we had the training
data we have the test data and now we
want to compare the two different data
data points how well did our predictions
actually do against some test data that
we held back that wasn't used for
training so this is actually the table
we get right here so we have the true
cost that we know about and we have a
predicted cost since it's maybe a little
hard to to look at and understand
there's also visualization so that's one
of the cool things also of jupiter's
notebooks that use all these
visualization libraries that are out
there for for python and you get kind of
a seed map where you based on a certain
true cost factor you see the spectrum of
what was predicted right so here you
have the true cost here you have to
predict cost and this is a pretty good
visualization giving you no idea how
well are we doing and maybe this is for
you an indication for you to go back up
and maybe do some parameter tuning and
some some try some things out do a
different split maybe on on training and
test and these type of things until
you're at a quality that is good enough
for for your use case okay now I'm at
the point where we actually have a model
and and what we're not doing here is
we're not training this again on cloud
ml on a billion data points because we
don't have the time for you all to see
how you know how long this takes so we
are going to keep the model as we have
it and we're going to we're going to
push it in cloud ml which means I can
give Reza in a second an API call that
he can use to ping ping the cloud ml API
and give it some value and these are the
values that are going to go and come
who pops up an airflow given some values
and make a prediction and on what should
be a tit you should be you know what
what action should be taken so what you
could do actually is right you give it
two numbers you give it maybe the
current temperature indications and the
and then you can say okay the way it's
going right now I might the way the
temperature is moving right now what is
the temperatures one degree higher or
two degrees higher what would my actual
cost be so you get two values back and
that could be an indication for you to
take action now or wait two minutes
because the cost actually of turning the
a/c on in two minutes is going to be
actually lower so this is the the type
of back and forth that I can now give to
Reza that she can now hopefully without
having to tear down as pipeline that he
built can actually use in in the
architecture that he'll be demonstrating
in a second great so I think we go back
to slide yes right yeah thanks so the
key component that I'm actually going to
have to swap out is that check that I
was doing against the temperature so
before if we remember our pipeline we
had IOT devices or sending streams of
data to pops up pub/sub was consumed
being consumed by data flow we were
splitting the data sending it to
bigquery which allowed Alex to be able
to do his work on the other side we had
that simple test where I was doing a
sliding window of five minutes every 15
seconds calculating the mean and doing a
check now I just need to replace that
with the inference that we have now and
I also no longer need that sliding
window so that sliding window was just
there for me to get an average rather
than go point by point here the system
can just take each point by the values
that we have and then give it the give
us a prediction back so the one thing
I'll need to do is change from that
check threshold where I was just
checking the temp at you against 30
degrees to the new code which is to call
the inference API
and the the inference endpoint is the
one that has been deployed with that
version number we have the package shape
that I need to send to it so that
package shape is a JSON structure that
I'll need to put together that JSON
structure comes from the same data that
I was collecting before so in order to
actually switch this out I will just
need to replace my checksum with a rest
call to the cloud ml service and then
from there the cloud ml service is going
to give me a prediction back that
prediction back will be in JSON format I
need to just extract the piece of data
that says whether the fan should come on
or off and then through the same part of
the pipeline I will actually send it on
to the factory and it will decide
whether to it should be on or off so if
we could just go back to this laptop
please okay so previously the section
that we hadn't shown was this middle bit
which was taking that data and instead
of doing the 5 minute sliding window
it's actually calling the prediction
service we get the output from the
prediction service I have a simple JSON
deep serialization to take the values
that I want out up on that and then I
send it again on to both pub/sub and
firebase we go to firebase I'll actually
go up a level now we can see two data
points one was the original flow which
has got check weather over 30 degrees
the other one is now the inference being
called from the cloud ml service and the
reason actually we want to keep both
running is like any good data engineer
I'm not going to just switch over from
production in a second right this is all
good stuff I trust that Lex is done a
great job what I want to make sure
everything continues working before I
make that switch and this is where we
start doing the a/b testing right in
this case we're a testing a very old
basic method of checking when the fan
should come on
with the new inference model but as time
moves on let's say this is all very good
successful and I actually make the
switch we're going to have different
models being built so maybe Alex decides
that actually given the data set every
week we want to rebuild the model maybe
it's everyday
whatever it is the cloud ml service will
allow you to create different versions
of the model as you do that so you have
v1 v2 v3 v4 this allows me to continue
to make sure that I can do AV testing of
that new model so if it's happening over
the day and there's a new model landing
I can maybe decide that what I always do
as a matter of course it's 30% of the
workload will go to the new model 70%
will continue in the old model once I'm
happy everything's in place I can make
the switch data flow allows you to do in
situ updates so you can actually update
the data flow as it's running it will
take care of redistribution of code and
at that point switch onto the new model
until another model comes along and I
switch it back out and these are the
kind of things that allows us to take
the data science and actually make them
production and usable very very
efficiently ok so back over to light
could we get back to the demo machine
I'm sorry I want the demo that is the
demo machine juice right
so just to recap right first thing is in
order to do something like this in order
to do something like this to make it
easy notice that the first thing that
Reza did was that he made sure that he
took all the data before he did all the
sliding windows before he did AG all the
aggregations there is this nice little
thing that there's right raw data to BQ
that's where everything starts if you're
not storing data you're not going
anywhere this without going to any place
that's auto-awesome
the first thing is save your data and
once you have saved the data we can then
go and that's basically that is the data
that Alex could basically use in his
data lab and you notice that his data
lab started with bigquery he Bey he went
into bigquery and said let me go ahead
and pull my data right B Q dot query
right that's essentially the basic first
step that you need to be able to do you
need to be saving the data in order to
base to go back and replace the kinds of
systems that you are doing now with
something better and cannot emphasize
this more make sure to save your data
notice some of the other things that
happened right as a Alex built of the
data lab model and he deployed it it was
a very simple cloud ml deploy it went on
to the cloud and he essentially got
something that could be called with a
REST API and raised and knew that he
didn't have to worry that this model
that Alex had built built by a scientist
was actually going to work in production
it was because it's basically running in
the cloud ml service and Razer could
simply invoke a invoke a REST API call
from his dataflow code now these are the
kinds of like engineering improvements
in guarantees that enable you to do good
data engineering and data science on GCP
right and and no razor went ahead and
pointed out a few other things like the
ability to do a/b
to be able to have both the old service
and the new service running at the same
time so you basically build confidence
in your business users before you
actually make the switch could you get
back to the slide please so bottom line
then that is this is now amazing time to
be a data engineer and a data scientist
and the reason is an amazing time to be
a data engineer a data scientist is that
the amount of work that you need to do
has gone dramatically down if you are
thinking about building machine learning
models the amount of work that you need
to do to build a machine learning model
fits in a single data lab notebook and
if you look at the code for that single
data lab notebook at the first start it
was all like no structured data go ahead
and preprocessor structured data go
ahead and train it was single no calls
on the Python API is a very easy way to
get started doing machine learning
starting the structured data and the
great time to be a data engine engineer
because again you can write dataflow
code and have all the DevOps and have
all the auto scaling or all of these
things be taken care of by the cloud
right so what exactly does auto-awesome
mean to you as a data engineer or as a
data scientist right as a data engineer
I think what it means is that whether
you're doing ingestion notice that Raisa
started out ingesting data with cloud
top sub and it could scale from tens of
messages to millions of messages from
local to global and he didn't have to
lift a finger right he just set up a
topic and that was it and then anybody
could basically post into that topic the
ingestion was also awesome
transformation how did razor to the
transformation
he used Apache beam Cloud dataflow he
wrote his code in Apache beam which is
totally open-source he executed it using
cloud dataflow on GCP and that
essentially again
in abled the transformation code to be
like automatic right and we talked about
how you can basically deploy a new
service and you can replace a running
pipeline how amazing is that right to be
able to replace a running pipeline to
not lose any messages in the process of
replacing a running pipeline that's
eating right when you say you can
replace a running pipeline what you're
saying is your old pipeline processes
until certain message and the new
pipeline takes on at the next message
are you not actually lost any message in
the process that you can replace a
running pipeline with no confirmation
and the other thing we cannot gloss over
it a little bit but as the dataflow
pipeline was writing things out there's
writing them into bigquery and we could
be querying the data even as it was done
you saw the firebase app the firebase
app was making a query into bigquery
even as the data was streaming in okay
again if we made it look very easy
rather this was extremely extremely hard
think about being able to do querying on
streaming data right we're doing sequel
queries on streaming data to power that
fire based graphical thing and finally
to be able to do your training on your
machine learning model okay and the good
thing is that all of this will Auto
scale to thousands of machines on demand
all we are writing is your writing code
I'll be writing code we're defining the
logic and everything else is just auto
scaling the odd the other thing that we
took huge advantage of was that when
Alex did his training he was training it
on batch data but then when we did the
predictions we were predicting on
streaming data right and it was actually
a very easy transition and the only
reason it was a very easy transition was
that razor was using data flow and data
flow is a programming model that lets
you deal with batch data and streaming
data in exactly the same way so we could
train a model on historical data which
is what you
always do but you predict on newly
arriving data which is what you always
want and we didn't get into this but the
model that Alex built that was his first
model and over time will need to do
hyper parameter tuning will need to tune
the models and all of that is also
automatic at all of these things about
tuning your model making them better
right those can also be all part of your
whole process of making them completely
automatic so bottom line then right what
did it what GCP offers to data
scientists to data engineers is that we
offer a way to fuel your innovation you
write your innovation we give you the
rocket ship we give you the rocket ship
to fuel your innovation like whether
you're talking about ingestion which
pops up you're talking about
transformation with dataflow you're
talking about analyzing your data with
bigquery doing your experimentation with
data lab you're doing machine learning
with Cloud ml it all just works and that
stuff's like ultimately the thing that
that makes it all you know it all girls
all very well integrated and it provides
you a huge amount of innovation so quick
shout out to related sessions today at
2:40 p.m. there is an IOT solution on
Google cloud and there is an another
talk on Apache beam how to do portable
and parallel data processing so both of
those are very related to this session
in terms of being able to do stream
processing and if you looked at this
session and say hey these are all the
kinds of things that I do these days
strongly encourage you to go visit the
certification lounge the data engineer
certification on Google cloud is
currently in beta so it's discounted so
please go ahead and give it a try that
you can you can take the exam right here
you're asked at next and thirdly the
shameless plug there is a my book data
science on GCP which basically goes on
you know ingestion all the way to
machine learning kind of same kind of
thing that we talked about here but
using a use case that's around
predicting flight delays how to ingest
data and then go all the way to doing
streaming real-time predictions using
time windows etc so which I step you
through this entire process the book is
an early release so you can go to the
O'Reilly website you can start reading
the book now so thank you all very much
[Applause]
you